evening from London and welcome to Piers
Morgan on Center the coronation of King
Charles is a global spectacle the eyes
of the world will fall on Britain
tomorrow in our royal family for all the
right reasons Charles will be the 40th
Monarch crowned at the mighty
Westminster Abbey which has hosted every
coronation since William the Conqueror
in 1066. just think about that for a
moment that's the history of this great
country well almost 1 000 years of that
history will echo through that Great
Hall as world leaders have gone and
millions are glued to screens across the
world the ceremony will feature Rings
swords and scepters dating centuries
Charles III will be Anointed with holy
oil poured from an 800 year old spoon
he'll ride back to Bucky and Palace in a
260 year old crown on Wheels the gold
State coach which is dazzled crowds and
rattled the teeth of Royals since the
days of William IV frankly it is what it
should be the stuff of fairy tales and
there can't be a nation anywhere on
Earth that can rival Britain for this
kind of tradition history of the
celebrating stedications with Pomp
pageantry and style
that Journey from Miami to the Palace is
just 1.3 miles but this coronation is in
many ways the Journey of a lifetime the
world has watched Childs as he grew from
a grinning child into a loving father
and a sometimes cantankerous Prince we
speculated for decades about whether the
public would Embrace his elevation to
the crown about whether he could rise
from a shadow of a mother and queen who
seemed infallible at times but now that
moment has arrived and for many people
Charles is not only accepted but
celebrated the Camilla the queen and the
love of his life this has been a journey
like no other two she was The Outsider
shrouded by the memory of Diana so often
Savage by the media reviled by many of
the public but tomorrow she becomes
Queen Camilla and much of a nation has
embraced her strength her wisdom her
empathy and her just get on with its
sense of Duty these are tumultuous times
for the monarchy though there's no
denying that the end of the Elizabethan
age which span changes unprecedented in
history is a major test not just for
King Charles but for the country
Britain's monarchy has faced a scandal
of an errant prince Andrew an
unparalleled Hale of poisoned darts from
the Rogue Royals in Montecito but it's
still here it's still strong and
tomorrow we'll see again but it's still
bringing us all closer together in my
opinion the monarchy keeps our sense of
nation and patriotism separate from
politics it gives us all a reason to
love our country it's traditions and its
identity that rises above The Fray of
the bitterness of everyday debate there
are massive challenges for King Charles
make no mistake about that will today's
young people embrace the Royals well the
Commonwealth survive can an institution
build on stoic silence and illogical
birthrights survive and thrive in the
age of identity politics populism and a
rage against the elites so yes there are
questions about the very future of the
monarchy and there are questions too
about Britain's role in the world at
this turning point of the eras but not
today
this is King Charles's day tomorrow and
it's Britain's day there's been a lot of
negativity in the build up to this
momentous moment there always is the
protester polls the tales of an
apathetic public but what it really
comes down to it I think we do love our
country we love our traditions and we
certainly love a good bloody party let's
do what we do best have a cake have a
quiche wave a flag raise a pint and
enjoy it and for everyone else as my own
son observed this week on Twitter you
may not care about the coronation but I
can very much assure you nobody cares
that you don't care